This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you know anything about Central European cities, when you hear Warsaw, you think, grey, ugly, communist. But there is a part of Warsaw that is anything but those things, the old town. Walking through these strict districts, it's just like any other Quaint European city. Tour shops, horse carriage rides, church buyers. The buildings are beautiful. But actually, it's all fake.
这里是“99%无形”（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。如果你对中欧城市有所了解，每当听到华沙这个名字，你就会想到：灰色、丑陋、充满共产主义气息。但华沙有一个地方与这些词毫不相干，那就是老城区。漫步在这些严整的街区里，它就像任何其他古雅的欧洲城市一样：旅游商店、马车游览、教堂集市。这里的建筑美轮美奂。但实际上，这一切都是假的。
It's just a replica of what once was. Like so many European cities during the Second World War, Warsaw was destroyed. It had to be rebuilt. Now when you walk around the reconstructed historic part of Warsaw, you'll find these big, last-mounted plaques on display on the sidewalk. In-memorold paintings of these historic buildings in front of you. The first time I noticed one of these displays on the Vyshwiat Street, and I was completely
它不过是昔日风貌的复制品。就像二战期间的许多欧洲城市一样，华沙被彻底摧毁了，不得不进行重建。如今，当你漫步在华沙重建的历史老城区时，你会发现人行道上展示着这些大型的、永久安装的牌匾。眼前这些历史建筑的早期画作。第一次我在维斯维亚特街（Vyshwiat Street）注意到其中一个展示牌时，我完全被
drawn in. I studied the painting, and then I studied the building above. And just like I was set up too, I thought, wow, they did an amazing job rebuilding it. But then later our reporter Amy Drostovska found out, it's not quite like that. You were entering something which is effectively a stage set intended to recreate
深深吸引了。我仔细端详着画作，然后又打量着上方的建筑。正如别人设计好的那样，我心想，哇，他们重建得太棒了。但后来我们的记者艾米·德罗斯托夫斯卡（Amy Drostovska）发现，事实并非完全如此。你仿佛进入了一个实际上是舞台布景的地方，旨在重现
an atmosphere of a certain period, but you're unaware of that. That's me Haumodovsky, who was born in Warsaw, now he's a social anthropologist at Cambridge University. He told me about the incredible process of putting the city back together again. It's a challenge a lot of European cities were facing after the war. Warsaw's massive rebuilding of its entire medieval old town was lauded as one of the most impressive rebuilding post-war projects on the continent.
某个特定时期的氛围，而你却对此浑然不觉。说话的是哈莫多夫斯基（Haumodovsky），他出生于华沙，现在是剑桥大学的社会人类学家。他向我讲述了将这座城市重新拼凑起来的不可思议的过程。这是战后许多欧洲城市面临的挑战。华沙对其整个中世纪老城区的大规模重建，被誉为该大陆上最令人印象深刻的战后重建项目之一。
They made it look to everyone, like they reclaimed what was lost. But here's the thing, Warsaw's historic old town is not a replica of the real thing. It's a reimagining, an historic city that never really was. So let's back up for some history. Sure, Warsaw is damaged during the war as were other cities. But really Warsaw, occupied by Nazi forces, got hit particularly hard. One of the worst cases in the whole war. Practically the whole city was destroyed.
他们让每个人都觉得，他们夺回了失去的东西。但问题是，华沙历史悠久的老城区并不是真实原貌的复制品。它是一种重新想象，是一座从未真正存在过的历史名城。让我们回溯一下历史。当然，华沙在战争中受到了破坏，其他城市也是如此。但事实上，被纳粹军队占领的华沙遭受了尤为沉重的打击，是整场战争中最糟糕的情况之一。几乎整座城市都被毁了。
People quibble about the exact statistics, but most agree it was something like over 80% of the core part of Warsaw. Really most of the city, especially the parts of Poles considered important. Tupada's for surviving Poles were an 11-hour attempt to take back their capital. Hitler gave an order. Pacify Warsaw. Raise it to the ground. A new of those stuff are buildings. Fight the Syroges and civilians, doctors and workers, pros and jewels, women and children.
人们对确切的统计数据争论不休，但大多数人认为，华沙核心区大约有80%以上被毁。可以说整个城市的大多数地方，特别是波兰人认为重要的部分。对于幸存的波兰人来说，图帕达斯（Tupada's）是一场持续了11个小时的夺回首都的尝试。希特勒下达了命令：平定华沙，将其夷为平地。其中许多都是建筑物。与叙罗吉斯（Syroges）人和平民、医生和工人、专业人士和珠宝商、妇女和儿童战斗。
They fight for a day. Two days. A week. Two. Three. Four. Five. Two, three, four, five. The destruction was focused on the most important buildings, on the most significant historical buildings, because they were identified with the past and with sort of national identity,
他们战斗了一天、两天、一周、两周、三周、四周、五周。摧毁的目标集中在最重要的建筑、最具历史意义的建筑上，因为它们被视为过去和某种国家认同的象征，
and that was exactly what was identified as the most important to get rid of by the Nazis. And as Warsaw burned, the Soviets, ready to take over after the retreating German forces, stood on the other side of the river and watched. Stalin's forces did nothing to help the Poles and the Warsaw uprising or save their city. It's not that he wanted the insurrection to fail because destroyed Warsaw would be that much easier to take over once the Germans were defeated. After the war, Warsaw was in ruins. It was liberated in January 1945, and this is when the inhabitants started coming back
而这恰恰被纳粹视为最必须消灭的东西。正当华沙在烈火中燃烧时，准备在德军撤退后接管政权的苏联人却站在河对岸冷眼旁观。斯大林的军队没有采取任何行动来帮助波兰人和华沙起义，也没有拯救他们的城市。并不是说他希望起义失败，因为一旦德国人被击败，被摧毁的华沙反而更容易被接管。战后，华沙变成了一片废墟。它于1945年1月解放，正是在这个时候，居民们开始返回
to Warsaw, and there's all these descriptions of people sort of, you know, absolutely shocked bags and hands just wandering around, dazed, unable to find their old homes, and unable to recognize anything. This was Warsaw. Maybe again, after a year, the true meaning of that battle will be assessed by soldiers and historians. Maybe a bigger and more beautiful city will be built on the ruins, to be the capital of a new and better Poland. But this one died a soldier's death for the common cause. And to die in the capital to another city. But instead, Pulse decided to start over from scratch.
华沙。有各种各样的描述说人们，你知道的，手里拎着袋子，极度震惊地四处游荡，神情恍惚，找不到自己以前的家，什么也认不出来。这就是华沙。也许再过一年，这场战役的真正意义将由士兵和历史学家来评判。也许废墟之上会崛起一座更大更美丽的城市，成为崭新且更美好的波兰的首都。但这座城市为了共同的事业，像士兵一样阵亡了。死在首都，总好过死在别的城市。然而，波兰人决定从头开始。
Much of the city was rebuilt according to communist plans, fast, cheap, and big. Apartment blocks, wide avenues, heavy-gray buildings, communist ideology, and architectural form. But when it came to the historic district of Warsaw, the old town and a long connecting section called the Royal Root, they decided to restore not just rebuild. And with the way planners were going about it, the historians, archaeologists, all the specialists involved. It really seemed like they were going to bring old Warsaw back to life. There was this incredible focus on authenticity in rebuilding the Old Town, so there was really an emphasis for the Old Town to be built from the same physical matter as the Old Town was. So, the special kilns were built on the outskirts of Warsaw, where the rubble from the Old Town was taken and made into bricks from which the Old Town was to
城市的很大一部分是根据共产主义规划重建的：快速、廉价且宏大。公寓大楼、宽阔的大道、厚重的灰色建筑、共产主义意识形态与建筑形式的结合。但当谈到华沙的历史街区——老城区以及被称为“皇家之路”（Royal Root）的漫长连接路段时，他们决定进行修复，而不仅仅是重建。从规划者、历史学家、考古学家以及所有参与其中的专业人士的做法来看，这真的好像是要让老华沙起死回生。在重建老城区时，人们对“真实性”有着不可思议的专注，因此非常强调老城区必须用与原老城区相同的物理物质来建造。因此，在华沙郊外建造了特殊的窑炉，老城区的瓦砾被运到那里，烧制成砖块，老城区将用这些砖块
be rebuilt. And the bricks that were reusable, that were just sort of lying around in the rubble, they were collected and they were cleaned and they were sort of polished up and they were used in building these new old buildings. It took several years, but they did it. And when the new old town was first opened, people were happy, ecstatic to have it back. Even in the west it was seen as a major accomplishment, a kind of victory after all the destruction of the war, a triumph of the human spirit. The pictures from the time show a sort of carnival as it was unveiled. You can see it from old photographs, people are joyfully wandering around this miraculously recreated place,
进行重建。而那些可以重复使用、只是散落在废墟中的砖块则被收集起来，清洗干净，打磨一番，用来建造这些“崭新的老建筑”。这花费了好几年的时间，但他们做到了。当这座全新的老城区首次开放时，人们感到高兴，甚至欣喜若狂，因为他们失而复得。甚至在西方，这也被视为一项重大的成就，是战争毁灭后的一种胜利，是人类精神的凯旋。当时的影像资料显示，揭幕时犹如一场嘉年华。你可以从老照片中看到，人们欢欣鼓舞地在这处奇迹般重现的地方漫步，
which they thought had disappeared forever. This is something that made millions of people very happy, and that thousands of people, of ordinary people participated in. It was really a very successful social of social sort of dirty exercise. So the old city was brought back to life. After a bit of time though, people started to notice something kind of strange. It seemed like Old Warsaw was a little bit off. There are these descriptions that David Crowley, who's an art historian, wrote a book on
他们原以为这个地方已经永远消失了。这让数百万人民感到非常幸福，数千名普通民众也参与其中。这确实是一次非常成功的社会层面的“涤荡”锻炼。于是，老城区重获新生。然而过了一段时间后，人们开始注意到一些有些奇怪的现象。似乎老华沙有点不对劲。艺术史学家大卫·克劳利（David Crowley）写过一本关于华沙的书，
Warsaw, talks about of people who knew the old town before the war, wandering around and instead of feeling this kind of uncanny disjuncture between the city that they remembered and the city that they're wandering around now. So it was almost the same, it felt incredibly corresponded very closely to what they knew before, but then something wasn't quite right. Remember what I said earlier about Orsau's old town not being a recreation, but instead a reimagining? It turns out that despite all that effort to use the exact same bricks from the rubble, that show of authenticity was just that, a show. Like Morovsky said before, a sort of stage set.
其中提到了一些在战前就了解老城区的游人们的描述。他们四处漫步，产生了一种难以言喻的割裂感——一边是他们记忆中的城市，一边是他们现在漫步的城市。它几乎是一模一样的，感觉与他们战前所知的极其契合，但又有某种地方不太对劲。还记得我刚才说过华沙老城区不是一次重现，而是一次重新想象吗？事实证明，尽管付出了巨大努力去使用废墟中的原装砖块，但那种对真实性的展示仅仅也只是——一种展示。正如莫罗夫斯基（Morovsky）之前所说，这就像是一种舞台布景。
And this is highlighted even more so by the fact that, you know, the facades, the cobbles, everything seems absolutely fine, and then you wander through a doorway, and you wander into effectively a sort of modern staircase, and into a modern flat, with this kind of historical exterior. So there was this sort of very uncanny sense. It's not just that the builders concentrated on the exterior of the buildings and didn't bother creating what was behind them.
这一点甚至更加凸显：你知道的，外墙、鹅卵石，一切看起来都绝对没问题，然后当你穿过一扇门，走进的却实际上是一种现代化的楼梯间，进入了一间现代化的公寓，而外表却是这种历史风格。因此，有一种非常诡异的感觉。不仅是因为建设者只专注于建筑物的外部，而懒得去管它们背后是什么。
Warsaw's new historic district was incredibly odd by design because actually it was different. It was never supposed to be exactly the same as it was. So there's this weird disjunction between this incredible emphasis on authenticity, old bricks being reused and special kills being built for this purpose, this big focus on continuity, physical continuity. But at the same time there was a very clearly stated idea that the old town shouldn't be the same old, there was a very clearly stated idea that the Old Town shouldn't
华沙崭新的历史街区在设计上极其古怪，因为实际上它是与众不同的。它从来就没打算与过去完全一模一样。因此，这里存在着一种奇怪的脱节：一方面极度强调真实性、重复使用旧砖并为此建造专用窑炉、高度关注连续性（物理上的连续性）；但与此同时，又有一个非常明确的观点，即老城区不应该是旧的，有一个非常明确的观点，即老城区不应该
be the same Old Town as before 1939. It should be better than it was, so it should be a more perfect Old Town than existed before the war. Before the war, ironically, Warsaw's historic Old Town was slowly fading away on its own. Before the war was basically, it was a slum. It was more or less a sl Islam. It didn't have proper sewage facilities, it didn't have proper draining. It was basically lived in by very poor inhabitants
是1939年之前的那座老城。它应该比过去更好，应该是一个比战前更完美的旧城区。说来具有讽刺意味的是，在战前，华沙历史悠久的老城区正在慢慢自行消亡。战前它基本上就是一个贫民窟。它或多或少就是一个贫民窟。它没有合适的排污设施，没有合适的排水系统。这里基本上住着非常贫困的居民，
with a few kind of churches and obviously the cathedral was in it and the royal castle. But beyond the castle square, the old town square was the location for a sort of haphazard market and wasn't considered to be a particular sort of prestigious part of the city. It had been sort of ruinedphazard market and wasn't considered to be a particularly sort of prestigious part of the city, it had been sort of ruined over time. But after the war, reeling from loss piled upon loss, historic Warsaw took on a new meaning. Now that it was missing completely, it had more power and Polish people's memory than if it was around, no matter what the form. So to the communist way of thinking, the old town needed to be rebuilt so that it
只有几座教堂，显然还有大教堂和皇家城堡。但在城堡广场之外，老城广场是一个杂乱无章的市场的所在地，并不被认为是城市中特别享有声望的部分。随着时间的推移，它已经有些破败不堪，杂乱无章的市场，并不被认为是城市中特别享有声望的部分，随着时间的推移，它已经有些破败不堪。但在战后，经历了接连不断的沉重打击后，历史上的华沙被赋予了新的含义。既然它已经彻底消失了，无论以何种形式，它在波兰人民记忆中的力量反而比它存在时更强大。因此，在共产主义的思维方式看来，老城区必须重建，这样它
could be forgotten. The cynical argument is that the old town was rebuilt as a sort of ideological camouflage. So in order to mask the fact that Poland was being taken over by a sort of alien power, this alien power decided to rebuild the whole town to make it seem like they had some sort of respect for Polish culture and Polish history, whereas in reality they were sort of undermining everything, undermining the old, the social structure, everything that came before them. It's like this, if Warsaw's historic capital just got leveled over and replaced by gray, ugly apartment blocks, people
才能被遗忘。一种愤世嫉俗的说法是，重建老城区是一种意识形态上的伪装。为了掩盖波兰正被某种外来势力接管的事实，这种外来势力决定重建整个城镇，使其看起来好像他们对波兰文化和波兰历史怀有某种敬意，而实际上他们却在破坏一切——破坏旧制度、社会结构以及他们之前的一切。这就好比：如果华沙的历史首都直接被铲平，取而代之的是灰暗、丑陋的公寓大楼，人们就会
would long for what they were missing. They'd remember their significant city, the seat of the nation's past. And not only long for it, they'd make a martyr of it. Their cherished past killed by communism, by the Soviets, the same Soviets, by the way, who stood on the other side of the river and watched Warsaw burn. And the communist would never win over the polls.
渴望他们失去的东西。他们会怀念那座意义重大的城市、这个国家过去的所在地。他们不仅会渴望它，还会将它奉为烈士。他们珍视的过去被共产主义、被苏联人所扼杀——顺便说一句，就是那些站在河对岸看着华沙燃烧的同一批苏联人。而共产主义者将永远无法赢得波兰人的心。
So by bringing the old city back, the communists made it and hopefully their partners' destruction, forgettable. The past could stop being such a distraction and they could go about their business of overhaul in the country. So that's why they decided to rebuild the old town. But the communists did it in such a way
因此，通过复活这座老城，共产主义者让它以及他们的同伙造成的破坏变得容易被遗忘。过去不再是一种让人分心的杂音，他们就可以继续忙于改造国家的工作。这就是他们决定重建老城的原因。但共产主义者这样做的方式是
to keep their core ideals intact and this is where it gets really weird. When city planners were looking for inspiration on how to better rebuild Old Warsaw, they went back further than just before the war when the Old Town was far from its heyday. So rather than the 1930s, they looked to the 1830s. Take one of the most famous streets in the Old part of town, Novosviyat, New World Street. For decades before the war, Novosviyat Street was one of the liveliest places in Warsaw, full of shops, cafes, and hotels. Over time, the once uniform buildings there started
为了保持其核心理想完好无损，而这正是事情变得真正诡异的地方。当城市规划者在寻找如何更好地重建老华沙的灵感时，他们追溯的时间甚至比战前老城区远未达到鼎盛时期的年代还要久远。因此，比起20世纪30年代，他们把目光投向了1830年代。以老城区最著名的街道之一维斯维亚特街（Novosviyat，新世界街）为例。在战前的几十年里，维斯维亚特街是华沙最热闹的地方之一，到处都是商店、咖啡馆和酒店。随着时间的推移，那里原本统一的建筑开始
to take on different heights, as different owners would build on extra levels to expand and improve. And then when it was rebuilt, it was decided that this sort of bustling capitalist in a galletarian atmosphere of Novishviat was improper, and so it was rebuilt effectively in the image of how it would have looked in the early 19th century. In this sort of classicist, osfaliosteer, simple style, and nearly all the buildings were reduced to a height of three stories. And so this is sort of also, this is an attempt to make it into a egalitarian kind of enlightenment street, rather than a sort of nasty, capitalist sort of cutthroat laissez-faire street that
呈现出不同的高度，因为不同的业主会建造额外的楼层来扩建和改进。然后，当它被重建时，人们认为维斯维亚特街那种熙熙攘攘的、资本主义的、崇尚平等的氛围是不合适的，因此它实际上是按照19世纪早期风貌的形象进行重建的。采用了这种古典主义的、奥斯法利奥式（osfaliosteer）的、简洁的风格，几乎所有建筑的高度都被缩减到三层。因此，这也是一种尝试，试图将其变成一条崇尚平等的启蒙运动时期的街道，而不是19世纪那种
had been in the 19th century. And here's where it gets even weirder still. For other parts of Old Warsaw, the post-war city planners went back further still to the 1700s, to a city that never really existed. A city imagined by an Italian painter. Remember the sidewalk displays I mentioned earlier, the ones that show pictures of Warsaw before the war?
令人讨厌的、资本主义的、残酷的自由放任式街道。而接下来事情变得更加诡异。对于老华沙的其他部分，战后的城市规划者将时间追溯得更远，回到了1700年代，回到了一个从未真正存在过的城市——一个由意大利画家想象出来的城市。还记得我前面提到的人行道上的展示牌吗？那些展示战前华沙照片的牌子？
It turns out that the paintings are by an Italian named Bernardo Balota. He was what's called a vedutista, meaning he specialized in the Venetian art of realistically painting cityscapes and precisely documenting their details. He was invited to Warsaw in the late 1700s by the King of Poland to become court painter and make pictures of the capital.
事实证明，这些画作是一位名叫贝尔纳多·贝洛托（Bernardo Balotto）的意大利人画的。他被称为“威尼斯画派风景画家”（vedutista），这意味着他专门从事威尼斯艺术，即逼真地绘制城市风景并精确记录其细节。18世纪后期，他应波兰国王之邀来到华沙，成为宫廷画师，并为首都绘制画作。
To help his work, Balotto used a camera obscura, a predecessor of the photographic camera, and he had an incredible eye for detail. So the 20 plus paintings he created were a pretty remarkable document of what Warsaw looked like then. Except for one thing. Balotto had a tendency to make a few improvements. On one level, the paintings were incredibly precise, but on another level, Balotto was
为了辅助创作，贝洛托使用了一种暗箱（camera obscura，摄影机的雏形），并且他具有惊人的细节观察力。因此，他创作的20多幅画作成为了解当时华沙风貌的绝佳文献。除了有一件事例外。贝洛托有做一些美化的倾向。一方面，这些画作极其精确；但另一方面，贝洛托
very prone to making stuff up. So he didn't sort of steer away from indulging his artistic license. So you have, in several examples, he purified the buildings he was painting. Like adding a story to a building here, adding some decoration there, maybe changing the number of windows in a building, all sorts of little things that made the paintings
非常喜欢凭空捏造。所以他毫不避讳地放飞自己的艺术想象力。因此在几个例子中，你都可以看到他美化了自己正在绘制的建筑。比如给一栋建筑加盖一层，在那里添加一些装饰，或者可能改变一栋建筑的窗户数量，所有这些小细节都让这些画作
more pleasing to him. The King of Poland loved it. And so it turned out later, did the Communist. They liked Palotto's paintings because they showed a full range of society, not just the elite. They also liked his paintings because they were of the city before the heyday of capitalism, when Warsaw, as they saw it, was still pure. In fact, there was plenty of other documentation of Warsaw's historic section. A group of architects and students did painstaking work during the war before the destruction, creating blueprints, taking photographs. And a lot of those blueprints were used in the Warsaw reconstruction.
更合他的心意。波兰国王对此喜爱有加。事实证明，后来共产主义者也同样喜欢。他们喜欢贝洛托的画作，因为这些画作展现了社会的各个阶层，而不仅仅是精英。他们还喜欢他的画作，因为这些画作描绘的是资本主义鼎盛时期之前的城市，在他们看来，那时的华沙依然是纯净的。事实上，关于华沙历史街区的文献还有很多。一群建筑师和学生在战争爆发前的毁灭前夕进行了艰苦卓绝的工作，绘制了蓝图，拍摄了照片。其中的许多蓝图都被用于华沙的重建。
But when it came to rebuilding the old town, below Toe's paintings became the primary source. And now you can see the evidence. There's a building called John's House, which is a sort of 18th-century townhouse. You basically sort of added these kinds of freezes and carvings to the facade. I think the number of floors was changed as well. Some of the roof detailing was changed. If you look at a photo, if you compare a photograph of this building from 1939 and then a photograph of how it looks today and the painting,
但当谈到重建老城区时，贝洛托的画作成了主要的参考来源。现在你就可以看到证据了。有一栋名为“约翰之屋”（John's House）的建筑，这是一栋18世纪左右的城市住宅。你基本上可以发现，建筑立面上被添加了各种饰带和雕刻。我想楼层的数量也被改变了。一些屋顶的细节也被修改了。如果你看一张照片——如果你把这栋建筑1939年的照片与它现在的外观照片以及那幅画作进行对比，
you can see that basically the stuff that Bilotto added to the building exists now in reality. So his sort of flights of fancy were materialized in the way that the building looked after the war. So these historic Warsaw buildings like Johns house, they never existed, at least not like they do now. And the city continues to recreate itself in the form of these paintings. Recently they finished a huge remodeling of the royal route, widening the sidewalks, renovating a church facade. So it looks exactly like it does in Bologtoes paintings, but never like they actually looked
你就会发现，贝洛托添加到建筑上的那些东西现在真实地存在着。因此，他那种天马行空的想象力在战后建筑的外观中变成了现实。所以这些像约翰之屋这样的华沙历史建筑从来就没有真正存在过，至少不像现在这样。而且这座城市仍在以这些画作的形式不断重塑自我。最近，他们完成了对皇家之路的大规模改造，拓宽了人行道，翻新了教堂外表。所以它看起来和贝洛托画中的一模一样，但却从来不像它们在战前
before. It's like making an imaginary city come to life. In the end, Warsaw has its old town back. The groups of children on school field trips treat due to flu. Tourists conspicuously absent from the rest of the city, flock there. And Varsovian themselves, largely avoided. It's a place where you're kind of begrudgingly obligated to bring out of town visitors. You're a fisherman's wharf, you're navy pier. I'm sure you know and hate the one in your town.
实际那般模样。这就像是将一座虚构的城市带入现实。最终，华沙找回了它的老城区。参加学校春游的儿童群体蜂拥而至；在城市其他地方难得一见的游客们也纷纷涌向那里；而华沙本地人则大都避而远之。这是一个你有些不情愿、但又不得不带外地游客去的地方。这就好比你们当地的渔人码头（fisherman's wharf），你们的海军码头（navy pier）。我确信你一定知道并且讨厌你家乡的这种地方。
Maybe you'll walk through there on a Sunday or holiday with your family. But you don't think if it is the real Warsaw. It feels more like Disney's abcott center. There's a certain young hipster contingent in war saw that revels instead in the ugliest parts of the city, the failed communist experiment. They scoff at the old town because it's so fake, such tourist trash. But Muroski says they're wrong.
也许你会在周日或节假日和家人一起漫步穿过那里。但你绝不会把它当作真正的华沙。它感觉更像迪士尼的艾克赛特中心（Epcot Center）。华沙有一群年轻的嬉皮士，他们反而热衷于这座城市最丑陋的部分——失败的共产主义实验。他们对老城区嗤之以鼻，因为它是如此虚假，简直是旅游垃圾。但穆罗夫斯基（Muroski）说他们错了。
It's the old town that really represents what the city and the nation itself has been through. It's equal parts truth and falsehood, ideology and art, it's trauma and the entire recovery that comes after. 99% Invisible was written and produced this week by Amy Drostofska and Dave McGuire, with help from Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. It's a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook.
正是老城区真正代表了这座城市和这个国家本身所经历的一切。它一半是真相，一半是虚伪；一半是意识形态，一半是艺术；它是创伤，也是创伤之后彻底的复苏。“99%无形”本周由艾米·德罗斯托夫斯卡（Amy Drostofska）和戴夫·麦奎尔（Dave McGuire）撰写并制作，萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和本人罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）提供了帮助。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台KALW 91.7以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并关注这个节目。
I tweet at Roman Mars, but we have links to all the stuff we've been talking about and pictures of Italian paintings brought to life in Warsaw at 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我在推特（Twitter）上的账号是Roman Mars，我们在99percentinvisible.org上提供了我们一直讨论的所有内容的链接以及华沙复活的意大利画作的照片。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。